it was an historic address Obama was
welcomed like a returning son to the
Nelson Mandela plenary Hall
he started his speech talking about
human respect and dignity and a
countenance struggles this is the cradle
of humanity an ancient African kingdoms
were home to great libraries and
universities but the evil of slavery
took root not only abroad but here on
the continent colonialism skewed
Africa's economy and rob people of their
capacity to shape their own destiny
but Obama wanted to focus on the new and
modern Africa he highlighted the changes
that are currently taking place moving
the continent away from its old colonial
ties so many Africans have told me we
don't want just aid we want trade that
fuels progress we don't want patrons we
want partners who help us build our own
capacity to grow we don't want the
indignity of dependence we want to make
our own choices and determine our own
future Obama urged the continents
leaders to make their countries more
attractive to foreign investment by
cracking down on corruption nothing will
unlock Africa's economic potential more
than ending the cancer of corruption but
here in Africa corruption drains
billions of dollars from economies that
can't afford to lose billions of dollars
that's money that could be used to
create jobs and build hospitals and
schools the president's also touch on
democracy and said there was a long way
to go for many when it came to freedom
of speech and expression in Nigeria more
than 28 million voters bravely cast
their ballots and power transferred as
it should peacefully
yet at this very moment these same
freedoms are denied to many Africans and
I have to proclaim democracy is not just
formal elections Addis Ababa was the
last stop on Obama's African itinerary
his speech kept a five-day visit to the
continent